hello.  Choi Milton, everyone.  This is the
Chesley Morning
Brief for Thursday, June 18, bringing you happy investment plans.   I will
start with a part.
Yuri Pro just came running out of the bathroom [laughs] and I
thought he was Osain Bolt.   I will look into the
Chinese market yesterday, Director Wang.
Yes.  Uh, yesterday, with tech stocks rising, the
index was up 0.44% to 5.
Heungseung Tech Index maintained its level of
3.1 trillion, excluding the official massive 0.22%, 2%, and 5%
.  If
you look at the breakdown by industry, the IT, communication, and materials
sectors showed strong performance, while the energy,
consumer goods, and non-consumption sectors
showed weakness.  Yesterday as well, the surge in semiconductor and electronics stocks
continued.  Uh,
Language Tech is actually going up 5%.
Bupan Hwacheon rose 7%, Jomi
Semiconductor rose about 10%, Jangjeung
Tech rose 8%, Jangseung Tech rose
9.8%, and this is the stock
being researched.   It
recorded a 10% surge.
State-led strength was seen following the confirmation of an additional CCR price hike
.  I'm telling you to
come to Dongsan with a 3.2% subscription rate.  I'm telling you to come up 10% for the lead,
4.2% for the center, and 3% for the Kinboard
.
MLCC-related stocks
also rose on expectations of further price increases.
The speaker was set at 3.5%, and Bohwa Tech
reported 4.9% and 9% for all history.   The
dry market prescription also rose due to expectations for this period's performance and the
use of the dry market ignition type upward pressure
.  Jungje 5000-day
rose 2.2%, Shin Yeoksu rose 1.6%, and
Cheonbu Geondongsin rose 1.4%.
Stocks related to cooking oil surged again yesterday on expectations of further price increases following subsidies for the supply of cooking oil.  Chinese
giant ships hit the upper limit by about 10%
.  Oh, Honghwa Tech rose
2.9% and 9%, and Jeongjae Tech rose
10%. Both reported historical trends.   Stocks related to male
potency devices also rebounded due to an influx of funds buying at low prices
.  Tech No. 4 went
up 7%, Gilseo went up 3.4%, and
Yoshi's colleague went up 4%.  On the other hand, the number of
electric vehicle (EV) sales fell a bit yesterday due to factors such as sluggish EV sales indicators.
Yesterday, I said to lower the replacement interest rate for the belief property by 1bp
.  The specific interest rate for human objects was
slightly lowered yesterday, and the probability of externalization was told to avoid the portrait.
thank you  The Chinese market was rising along with the Korean market and the
Asian market in general, but
today I am just trusting that the overall market is not significantly different from the Korean or Japanese markets. The
question that suddenly came to mind yesterday—was it last
February that I said I would ask Manager Wang this morning?  That was when the Deepk incident
happened.  So, regarding the U.S., well,
not everything connected to that is 100% explanatory, but there were expectations for Nvidia's latest chips to be extracted by China, and there
were various sanctions like this. However, after that, Nvidia CEO Jen Shun and others in the U.S. argued that it actually
helps China develop its technological capabilities more rapidly, and therefore asked for the export restrictions to be
lifted.
Uh, a few days ago, wasn't the
latest version of Antropic's AI supposed to have foreign employees
?
There are regulations prohibiting external trade and exports, but I briefly wondered if these
things might actually help China's AI development. Since you will
be reviewing various materials to analyze the Chinese market and summarize the key stocks for us, I was curious if you happened to
see anything related to that among them
.  Well, regarding this, there has always been a
lot of talk about supply disruptions in competitions, hasn't there?   I'm
just going in a half-China direction.   They just
said they would open everything up to the public for free as a competition.
Ah, China is
correct.  So, you know that model China made these days?  There are so
many models that work with this Deep Chic look.   If you
have everything by company, there is a back center, a
lower bar, and a sale area.   They
said they would open the competition for free.  So, excluding the US, I made it possible to use multi-layered models from other
regions, such as South America, Europe, or Southeast Asia
.  So
[clears throat] the previous
school system for cutting this is also coming out differently.   The
strategy fits completely differently
.  So, I think there is a possibility that the situation could escalate, excluding the US, with
MS or other factors
.   hmm.
So, in that case, it is
usually referred to as open source. Do you make it so that a
huge number of people use it, and
then ultimately turn it into a paid product?
What happens?
[Laughs]
Because I am doing it, but the token
price is too high right now.  So, regarding the
supply, if we add more supply later, the
token amount sometimes has to go down.
So this isn't a P request, it's a Q
request.
So P can keep flying,
but since Q is going up, it can get much better through the transfer
.   hmm.
I see  [Clears throat]
In this broad framework, if
we look three or five years from now, we will likely see whether that major direction was
correct or successful. However, since you
mentioned that the directions of the two countries are completely different...   Let's take a look at what
other policy changes there are based on those criteria
.   yes yes
.
thank you  Yes, the trending stocks below for today are...
Have the Kingboard Aminades ever done that? Yes, yes.  We will make an
announcement once in May.   However, regarding this Hoja,
rather than May, the
organizer has already come out as such.
Currently, Ford PfR is around 38 times, and if
you look at Ford PfR, it
is about 15 times.  It's really expensive.   The
younger one is about 28.5%.   We are
maintaining the top position in the global CCR market with a 15% market share.  It is the
world's largest integrated company showcasing the E-Class driving line.   This
Hong Kong company
actually makes announcements every six months, just like last year.  We just do one semi-annually and
one annually.  There are
no branches.  Well, you can choose.   yes
.  You can do it with or without a break
.  Sales at the end of last year
increased.  The rankings
increased, and at that time, the consultation was 14%
mutual.  The GP margin is
19.5% and 5%.  Agreement
1.9% for the prostitution fee and MP My 12%
came out.  CCR and cooking
Seonyudong product PQ Donban Hwada
were effectively completed according to the results.  And
the price of this CCR has been rising recently
.  Originally, price increases are decided about four times in total compared to the beginning, and the
phosphoric acid rate
is usually around 10%.  It
was increased by 10% monthly, especially at the end of May.
However, on June 10th, the 6-month period was
finalized with an additional 15% increase.  I
greeted that 15% first.  So originally, the
leakage rate was increased by 68%.  Back in
May, regarding the capital atmosphere,
that is how the talk came out.
Based on the cooking line, public supply, and supplier assistance, the market price
was judged to increase further. Regarding the short circuit, it
was judged that the price would increase by 30% in May and by 50% to 70% until the end of the year.  So, it has already
sufficiently surpassed his level.
If the CCR price increases by 10%, there is a possibility of an 8% win against this company's GP
.  A
related report on C-City was released at the end of the month.
Originally, regarding the shelf, the profit
margin increased by 297%, and the profit
margin is 21.4%, which
is likely to more than double compared to the same period of 4%.
It is expected that the market price will rise based on the supply of cooking goods, triggering a sales revitalization effect, and that the market price will maintain its strength in the second half of the year.  The annual ASP is
about 225 Hong Kong dollars.  I
envied 80% agreement.  However, the
spot price sentiment for that month had already reached 245 dollars
.  So, if you imagine it, it
becomes 238 months.  The ratio compared to the estimate has already
gone up.
However, the problem is that it is currently 5% in June.
If it's 10% in July, 10% in August, and
10% every month until the end of the year, then this is the true
story.   yes
.  This is how it turned out on the fingerprint.  Because we do
n't know if we'll know by next month,
assuming 10%, it might
turn out to be double the estimate.  Because
CC and cooking explanation accompanying
the change, the EPS for next year and the year after next
was originally estimated at 2.7, 3.99, and 5.4 yuan respectively, and
has been adjusted upward by about 7%, 12%, and 12% compared to the branch.
Next year, I applied 25x multiplier, so the TP
was Jace with Baehonggongdal.  It has
risen 25% compared to the previous week and is down 12% from yesterday's closing price
. This company has a 3-year
CPS CG of about 90%.
So, if you do history with PG, there is
no one but the inflammation senior.   yes
.   Right now, it's too much
.  That is the case.
[Laughs]
Yes.  Should I call this a component related to the circuit board
?  Well, should I
call it raw materials?  We are a
materials company, and
looking at the middle of this, you mentioned a decision to further
increase CCL prices due to a shortage of glass fibers. When you
stated that the cumulative increase would be about 50 to 70 percent, I wanted to ask if raising prices by
50 to 70 percent in a single year is
n't a bit aggressive. However, since we have seen memory
prices
rise five or tenfold over the course of a year, I don't see it as saying the
prices are too high based solely on numbers without concrete data.
I don't think I can tell you this anymore.   The
table below appears to be
data from a foreign aggregation agency or securities firm. It shows
annual rankings, EPS, EPS
growth, PERP/BR, ROE, and... uh, I assume
this is the dividend yield for yield dramas.   yes
.   It follows the
typical pattern of a growth stock; it
appears to be a company with operating leverage, where profits surge as sales increase. One surprising thing, however, is that
looking at next year and the year after—just like this year—the dividend yield is
rising despite the increase in the stock price. In other words, it
generates a significant amount of cash flow. For a growth stock, a yield of
3% or 4% is
not bad.  that's right.  Because the company has
hardly made any of those cast investments since around 2019.
Oh, or maybe
I also looked up the CC and angle after the period.   The
historical peak is nearly 370 dollars
.
Hmm,
$375—that was the very attempt of the PC era
.  Compared to then, I kept going down with 370
.   yes
.   hmm.
So, regarding this, the annual
price we are looking at right now is roughly 200 to 238, right?
If the monthly
fees for July and August are really increased by 10%,
this price could exceed 3.7 million won by the end of the summer.
Right now, we are discussing the supply shortage over this side, but
here, well, we probably still have
no thoughts about KES investment or KEPCO investment.  So, I decided on
this.  I've already decided on that Q.
So P can be raised, and
so this estimate
[snorted] a bit, probably a bit tame
.
If, here, the KES investment—or rather, the
KEPA investment—increases by 10%, we
can probably install a story as well, so let's
keep an eye on one castle every month.
All right.  Hey, company Kingboard
Laminate.   yes
.   There may be some of
our Choiton members who are directly investing in laminates, and that is
correct.
What can investors in Korea apply to their investments after hearing about this company's performance and Manager Wang's outlook?   This
is Doosan.
[Laughs]
Doosan is probably in a similar situation. Yes, that's
right.   To be
more precise, it is a subsidiary of Doosan, right?
Doosan Electronics, well, first off, the
garrison [laughs]
listed stocks, and we need to see how it holds up
.  With that in mind, we will conclude our look at the
Chinese market here
.  Yesterday [snorting] Let
's take a look at the US market.  It seems like the
atmosphere has changed a lot since Kevin Ho's speech, Yuri Pro
. Yes, that is
correct.  Oh, I imagine many of you are watching this on your way to work today, and
I was
listening to it on my way to work as well.  So, I will start by
talking about the US market on Wednesday, the 17th.  Now,
looking at the results, you have probably seen this expression a lot by now: it was
hawkish.  I suppose they
mean something like it was poison pretending to be a thief
.
Rather than focusing on the keyword "external," I think the important thing is to examine what specific
numbers were released and what remarks led the
market to perceive this external nature. I want to
look into why the already sensitive market was so significantly shaken by those statements.  First of all, when we
talk about the FOMC, the 'Shi' is attached to the end, so it is a
meeting body.
So, when we say the FMC made an announcement, we
must view it as a single comprehensive package that includes not only the base interest rate but also the statement, the SP dot plot, and the Chair's press conference.  So, especially since
SCP is an
economic outlook chart that shows how Federal Reserve members view growth rates, experimental rates, inflation, and benchmark interest rates,
SP was a somewhat important
factor yesterday.  Now, amidst the
global trend of upward adjustments in interest rates,
and as you
can already see on the Pad Watch, the
maintenance of the US benchmark interest rate—that it will remain at around 3.5 to 3.75—was somewhat expected
.  However, the problem is that
in the SCP economic outlook table I just mentioned, the
price and interest rate forecasts for PC and core PC at the end of 2026 have been
adjusted upwards.
The market now views the Fed's inflation as
sticky.  The reason we view this so cautiously is that the
inflation rate doesn't come down easily.   It
appears they have now accepted the signal that expectations for a price cut have become even more distant, assuming that it will hold out for a long time.  The press conference should have served as a buffer here, but it
failed to do so.  But in reality, regarding the 2%
inflation target, they will firmly
maintain it and proceed firmly.  Moving forward,
rather than making promises in advance through forward guidance—which had been used as an important policy tool since 2008—we have
firmly established the message that we will make decisions based on market reaction data
.  So,
rather than the interest rate freeze itself having a greater impact, it seems the market was
shaken because expectations are weakening and the Fed has somewhat reduced its guidance on how it plans to proceed.   Right
?  When I discussed the market yesterday, I
mentioned that volatility might increase due to the rise in credit margins and leveraged positions. If you
look at the VIX index today, it rose
from 16.41 to 18.43 won, an
increase of about 12.4% or 4%.  So, it
appears that investors are taking a stance of preparing for increased short-term volatility following the FMC
.  So, amidst these movements, if
you look at the major indices, they have
fallen quite significantly.  In particular, the
Nasdaq 100 fell the most, by 1.34%
.  The SP 500 has also
fallen, and if you look to the right and
see the sector breakdown, the extent of the decline has widened even further
.
Communications saw the largest decline at 3%, followed by
discretionary consumption at 2.7%, real estate at
2.5%, and essential consumption at 2.1%
.  Now, however, if you
return to the major water indices and
look at the Philippine index, it
rose by 1.38%.   hmm.   While there may have been a
reason for the significant 5% drop yesterday, the key point
seems to be that the semiconductor index, which is expected to influence the entire market, showed a different movement. I
viewed the fact that it rose despite the Fed's somewhat hawkish stance as significant.
So, if you move down and
look at the semiconductor sector first, Micron
rose 2.2%, AMD
1.1%, TSMC 1.6%, and
Intel 3.6%.  First of all,
Bernstein raised its
target prices for AMD, ARM, and Intel yesterday
.
I used the term "CPU Renaissance," and as is well known, it
further emphasized the logic that as AI shifts from arrest-centric to AI agent-based systems, the demand for CPUs is also increasing
.
Broadcom, which moved further up and is classified together with Big Tech, also
rose 4.4% yesterday.
Although it is somewhat associated with Big Tech, the
demand for such CPUs is also growing for Broadcom.
I think we can view this within the trend of chip demand growing together.
Since we are now producing Type A, a customer-customized semiconductor chip, we need to keep a close eye on Broadcom. As of
yesterday, the
company
made some kind of announcement.  Yesterday, they announced the terms of a tender offer to purchase
some forward contracts maturing between 2023 and 2038
for cash, with a
total purchase
limit of about $2.5 billion excluding interest
.  Rather
than viewing this as direct positive news, it seems more like a move to
repay or restructure some of the existing debt early.
[Clears throat] The fact that they are
able to make such a tender offer for bonds suggests
that the market trusts Broadcom's cash
flow and financial strength, and
interprets it as the company having the capacity to manage debt maturities and interest costs amidst a continuing high-interest rate environment
.  So, since we're on the big tech side, if you
look at other stocks as well, Meta and Amazon have dropped quite sharply
.  So, Apple, which rose a bit yesterday,
also fell by about 1.1%
.  Investors are likely
familiar with the media outlet Benzinga. There
was an exclusive report in the financial media mentioning that
Google and Beta are the most vulnerable companies in the era of AI agents
.  Of course,
further specific verification is needed, but the
key point in the reports is not so much about
who makes the AI ​​model
better, but rather that
existing advertising models
could weaken when an era arrives where AI agents perform searches, comparisons, clicks, and reservations on behalf of users. This argument has
been reinforced once again.  So, as I
briefly mentioned in the text below, in
yesterday's market, the direction
diverged somewhat between platform advertisers and infrastructure suppliers within the AI ​​sector.  And as
mentioned earlier, it seems reasonable to assume that the communication
sector experienced the sharpest
decline
.  In the case of Apple as well,
there was a monthly event yesterday and some exclusive interviews with the team.  There was
now a mention of a memory price increase from the team
.  It likely had an impact on the stock price as it could lead to cost burdens, consumer
price hikes, or concerns about slowing demand.
However, if we
look at it from the opposite perspective, it means that in return, chip
suppliers are passing on the price increases to Apple
.  So, the memory bottleneck is
leading to a bottleneck in equipment stocks, which
could lead to an overall rise in the value chain.  So, ultimately, it seems we can
view this as confirmation of the semiconductor bottleneck once again
.  So, actually, if you
move down to the memory sector,
CPU-related stocks
have risen, and equipment stocks performed particularly
well.  ASML rose 3.7%,
Applied Materials rose
4.4% and 3%, and Lamley Search rose 1.4% and
4%, with
Applied Materials and Lamley Search, in particular,
once again reaching 52-week highs
.  Now, the semiconductor equipment report from Citi that came out yesterday has given it
some weight
.   The
bull market in the semiconductor wafer production equipment market could now continue into 2028
.  So, I raised the
target prices for all three stocks: AM, Rem Research, and KL
.  There are three main reasons for this:
supply constraints from TSMC and memory manufacturers, the need for expansion, and the
progress of Intel and Samsung Electronics' foundry operations. Furthermore, just as I
mentioned earlier regarding the rise in CPUs, the
demand for AI agent-based products is increasing as the market shifts
.  Above all, the
key point of the report was that the DRAM
market is a favorable factor for land demand
.  There has been a prevailing view that, with the
overlapping shortage of DRAM supply and rising prices,
changes are emerging at the architectural level where NAND memory is actually being utilized more
.   In a
similar context,
hard disk stocks have been rising for three consecutive days, and this could be
linked to the strength of Wesson Digital and Seagate
.
Aside from semiconductors, if
we look at earnings value as a keyword, there was some buying pressure, and
parts of the power and industrial sectors held up
.  As I wrote below,
General Electric (GE)
rose by about 1.5% and Caterpillar by about 1.1%.  In the software
sector as well, Robinhood rose 8.7% and
7%, and it seems that individual momentum is continuing, combining
expectations for increased retail trading activity with a
technical breakout
.
SpaceX had been on a
continuous upward trend since its IPO, but today it
closed with a slight decline.  Now that interest rates are
maintaining high levels and valuations are
high, I think we can anticipate that stocks like Tesla and Palatier will be
affected in the same context from a long-
term perspective. However, since
all three stocks are currently on an upward trend, we need to evaluate them by looking at earnings
visibility as a key factor going forward. I
believe we might see some downsides as a result of the Fed reacting to the hawkish stance it took today regarding the future direction of interest rates.   hmm.  The
FOMC Vice President will cover this in more detail in Part 2, though
.  I would wrap up by saying that today was actually a day that
further confirmed the focus of attention on companies with clear earnings visibility, rather than the hawkish reaction
.  That's all.
[Laughs]
Why do you think I'm laughing?   To
summarize...
ah, I didn't laugh because I was summarizing it...
uh [snorted]
When Pro-Yuri was summarizing things here and there, I
thought that if Vice President Choi had done this part, he would have said that we need to focus our investments on companies that can overcome the high-interest rate environment, and Pro-Yuri
said exactly that.  thank you  Uh, is
there anyone you know in Yuri Pro who uses the initials KYM?   Do
n't you have any?  Yuri Pro has
n't even done anything yet, but they're already giving double thumbs up.
[Laughs]
So, since the K in KY stands for our Pro Kim Yuri, I'm not sure if he is her
father or an
acquaintance. That
father is David.
Oh, I see.  Yes, so someone who didn't know
started by giving a double thumbs-up before Yuri Pro could even speak.  That is because
we are part of the group that trusts and watches Yuri Pro [clears throat] that much
.  Uh, thanks to your explanation, everything really clicked in my
head. Just as you
mentioned, only
the companies capable of weathering the interest rate environment saw a
partial rebound yesterday. Overall, if we had
looked at the numbers for the SP 500 or NASDAQ stocks—specifically the ones that rose and those that fell—I
think there would have been far more stocks that declined.   yes
.  So those aspects
were distinctive yesterday, and as
everyone mentioned, it seems the
stock market fluctuated quite significantly after the SM FOMC meeting
.  We will take a closer
look at [snorting] in Part 2
.
Ah, I will move on to virtual assets.  Master
Junhyeok, uh, what happened? Yes, yes.   I will
tell you the most.  I looked up the
time when the FMC statement was made yesterday, and it was around
3:30
.  However, starting from that time, the
Nasdaq and various other stock markets
fell, showing a downward trend together
.  However, in the
case of Nasdaq futures, they showed a rebound after falling again
.  I would say that Bitcoin is
showing a trend where it is unable to rebound accordingly, and I
find that aspect continuously disappointing.  So,
looking at the continuing trend where it doesn't rise much when going up and falls along with the market when going down, it appears that the
Bitcoin price is currently
not being replenished in terms of supply and demand
.  I have been feeling lately that a lot of things are not being backed up, so please keep that in mind when
viewing this.  So,
we sometimes look at Bitcoin in advance, depending on whether the stock market is falling or rising
.  It would be
good to check it once in a while when you fall behind
.  Personally, I think that since the factors driving the recent decline are often linked to the stock
market, if you take
those factors into account, you might be able to
think, "Ah, there must be some kind of issue," when the price of Bitcoin drops
.  If
you look at the long-term Bitcoin chart, it is
following the same trend.   There is a
very high probability that it will move while acting as a strong resistance line around $66,000
.  As I am explaining this, you
should keep a close eye on the flow to see if it breaks through the 6-step mark. If it continues to
fail to break through there, I predict that it will likely lead to a correction phase where it either moves
sideways or gradually declines
.
If you look at the Bitcoin Lead Index, it is still
in the extreme peer zone,
recording around 22. You can consider this to be sufficient
.  Note: Spot
ETF outflows are minimal, but about 11 years have come in as of
June 16
.  So, while it is
good that the outflow has ended, the outflow continues to fluctuate—whether there is an
inflow or a back-and-forth—and
since the outflow is coming in quite significantly, you should view that aspect with a bit of understanding.
Yesterday, I
mentioned that the Bitcoin price was improving as the net inflow into HyperLiquid's Bitcoin spot ETF continued, and I think the situation is actually the
same here.
Actually, the more significant the net outflow of Bitcoin spot trading,
the more
negatively it affects the price; however, the
price does not necessarily jump just because it has turned to a net inflow. In other words, I would
say that the current trend shows various momentum factors acting solely as factors for a decline
.  First, regarding the
title, I wrote "Is it okay to raise funds for asset purchases using wireless stocks?", and there is something
called strc.  You can consider this as a
research preferred stock issued by STC's Strategy
.
Since its launch in August 2025, the
dividend rate was increased a total of seven times consecutively in September and October
.  Since this is a variable
dividend rate, the company is watching closely, and the price is
deviating too much from the par value.  So, if the face value is 100 but it
deviates too much from $100, you can
arbitrarily adjust the dividend rate
.  So, I think there could be an effect of
slightly inducing investments through the price increase
.  The
current dividend rate is 11.5%,
and the dividend
yield is 12%.   You can
understand this as being due to the significant deviation from the par value. As I
mentioned earlier yesterday,
when the stock price deviates from the par value, the company raises the
dividend rate to
attract investors. Therefore, if
you look at the chart on the bottom left, the stock price has
consistently
shown patterns where it drops but then returns to the par value.  As I mentioned, you can
consider this to be the case because the actual rate of return is continuously showing an upward trend.
There is a reason why I am mentioning S1C regarding strategy. I believe I introduced this once before, but I previously
stated that funding through strategy—specifically through the research subsidiary known as S1C—has become more common than funding through MSTR.
The chart on the right serves as supporting evidence for this.  So, the one on the right is
called STRC dominance, and this
yellow line is SC dominance.
Uh, regarding the trading concentration in Strategy's preferred stocks, the
concentration on STRC is rising significantly right now
.  You can view it in this flow
.  So, paradoxically, the price of Bitcoin is actually getting
worse, but they are
actively pursuing STRC as a tool for fundraising, and you can
consider the total market capitalization to be around 11 years.
So, it seems the trend is to raise funds using a tool called STRIC rather than continuing to trade other preferred stocks or MSTR
common stocks. In
that case,
I would like to briefly examine whether conducting STRIC at this time is very stable
.  Uh, regarding the current small driving
attempt method, the cash currently held by that
strategy is about 11 billion
.  So, as I mentioned earlier, currently there are about
104 million shares.  There are approximately
104 million shares, and dividends are
paid every two weeks.  Then, we have to
keep injecting 50 million every two weeks to
pay out dividends
.  You can assume that
approximately 1.2 billion won in dividends must be
continuously paid out annually, and
all of this is based on the assumption that the current par value is maintained
and the
current market capitalization does not increase further.
Therefore, if
STRC's market capitalization
increases and stock issuance expands, the amount of
dividends that
need to be paid
could increase significantly.
Currently, it is said that the company has the
capacity to hold out for about 7.7 years
.  This is a formula
derived from the dividend payment process
.  For example, if
Bitcoin crashes—and the
MNAB that companies are currently trading
relative to Bitcoin and
various other assets—falls sharply, and
then the
STRC I just mentioned crashes—
then the actual rate of return is bound to suddenly
skyrocket.   If
that happens because it deviates significantly from the clear price,
the probability of failing to pay dividends will gradually increase
.  Since it is not a convertible bond, the
dividend on the preferred stock may
not be paid this time.  It could just be
overlooked like this, but since the
obligation to pay does not disappear anyway, it is
structured in such a way that a bank run can occur while continuing to run dead spies
.  So, for example, if Yonsei Bitcoin
fails to pay dividends, the only
means for the investor to generate cash is
through MSTR or selling Bitcoin, so the
probability of selling Bitcoin becomes very high.  As I
mentioned, you can
view this as a continuing vicious cycle. As
I am stating now, there was
almost no inflow into ETFs in 2026
.   If we
look at it from a perspective of the spring, it is almost a
strategy, but since we bought Bitcoin,
if that strategy
collapses like this, it means that Bitcoin's only
advantage is collapsing.  Also,
MSTR is currently raising
funds through its research preferred stock, STRC. If a
situation arises where it is unable to pay dividends to
STRC, I would like to point out that this could lead to a sell-off of Bitcoin and the collapse of its sole source of demand. However, regarding strategy, I believe the most significant aspect is that this
downturn is coming to an end to some extent before this issue escalates and grows
.  So, while
we need to keep in mind that this structure itself could continue to remain vulnerable, I
think we just need to remember that this is an issue that will inevitably resurface and be mentioned at some point.  We are
proceeding with the prediction that the bear market is about 70% complete, and for
example, those parts were just the
beginning of the downturn.  However, if the
issue continues to be raised in the market that dividends might not be paid due to this, then
from 3D's perspective, it was a
flow where the dead spiral mechanism could have been triggered. But the
encouraging aspect is not that the
strategy structure has improved, but rather that the
bear market is coming to an end to some extent
.  The reason this is encouraging is that,
ultimately, if the price of Bitcoin improves,
stock prices related to Strategies or STICs are bound to improve as well
.  Because the value of Bitcoin per share is
rising, there will likely be more investments where people seek to
leverage the effect by investing in MSTR rather than investing in Bitcoin
.  So, if the Bitcoin price
rises, there is a high probability that STIC will
stabilize again at that time. However,
since it is currently a bear market, and considering it is ST and
MSTR, I
personally think that from a strategy perspective, the trend seems to be to just hold on a bit
.  If you look under Ethereum,
BitMy, Ethereum's DAT company,
originally did not hold those preferred shares
.  However, starting in June,
the preferred stock called BM BMNP was launched and is
currently being traded.  The dividend rate is
fixed at 5%, which is about 9.5%
.  So, it is
said that BitMine has to continue paying that dividend every week, amounting to about 640,640 K, and that it has to pay it for about 33 million years a year.  So, Ethereum,
BitMine, and Strategy are all facing
significant dilution of their underlying shareholder value. Therefore,
to defend against this during a market downturn, they are raising funds through research preferred stock and
investing those funds to purchase Bitcoin or Ethereum.  I
think you can interpret it this way.
Structurally, it may help to reduce shareholder value dilution
somewhat,
but since they are currently selling research preferred shares and
using the proceeds to purchase Bitcoin or Ethereum, I would like to
point out that structurally, this may not be very robust.
Because ultimately, this cash is
not being used for shareholder returns but is simply
remaining as cash to purchase assets, I would say that
question marks continue to be attached to these factors. In
any case, both ST
Strategy and BitMine are currently promoting themselves by showing how
the value of the Bitcoin or Ethereum they hold correlates with their
stock prices. Since
both companies are showing a trend of trying to weather the Bitcoin bear market, and given the
financials are intertwined in this way, what
we need to look at is the flow of how Strategy and
BitMine are currently holding out in the
market. That is why I
prepared this today.   That's
all.  Oh, thank you.  Although
some time has passed, I think there are a few things that are still
important, so I would like to mention them before moving on
.  Uh, I’d like to ask you about the scenarios where the Bitcoin
price stays stable or falls,
or where it gradually rises from now on
.  yes.
First of all, if the market hovers around the low $60,000s or
high $50,000s—whether it's
sideways, trading flat, or
fluctuating—it could
enter the negative vicious cycle you mentioned and
eventually lead to bankruptcy. I
think that is the correct way to understand it.   yes
.  Assuming an upward trend,
from the perspective of a strategic company,
cash flow—that is, cash entering the company—
usually comes from issuing
preferred shares or selling
existing Bitcoin.
Selling Bitcoin is somewhat of a separate matter, but
ultimately, when
new shareholders join—whether of preferred or common shares—cash is generated
within the company.
A portion of that is used to buy Bitcoin, and as I
mentioned, it
seems you pay dividends to holders of preferred shares every quarter, or rather every two weeks.  yes.  So, if I were a
shareholder holding preferred stock, and
could receive a dividend of about 11% or 12% per year, it is actually a bond that allows you to recover the
principal as long as it does not go bankrupt within 9 years
.
And if there is value in the preferred stock even then, it could be possible, so there is an added
bonus.  But
before that, if the company goes bankrupt, since I am a shareholder whether it is a preferred or
common stock, there is
no longer any possibility of recovery. However, if I were to say that I
want to participate as a preferred shareholder even now, it would essentially mean that
dividends are paid to existing preferred shareholders using the investment funds from those who, like me, wish to become new preferred shareholders. It is a bit of a Ponzi scheme, so
anyway, the structure is
bad.  I have this thought:
even if the price of Bitcoin shows an upward trend, the market capitalization of
Strategy
could rise because the valuation of the Bitcoin held increases. However, regarding the
cash flow generated through additional capital increases, if we simply keep
buying Bitcoin in the future, it would essentially
be a structure where we invest when things are good and increase capital again when things are bad. So, I do
n't think this would be very good for Joju.
What are your thoughts?   yes
.  So recently,
companies that DAT STRC are also emerging.  Therefore,
companies that exclusively buy this research preferred stock are also
emerging.  So,
structurally, if S strc
collapses, it is no longer a structure where only str collapses—
meaning only the shareholders investing in steady are
affected.
So, structurally, it is quite intertwined because there are people who invest in STRC and those who only
collect that
.  So, if these break out, I
believe a decline in the annual market could occur, and I
think what you said is correct.   I just
think of this as them playing a game of hot potato.  So, regarding
how we should view those aspects, this is actually the
first time we have experienced a bear market since STIC launched this during a bull market.  Since that happened, I think we need to keep an eye on how those aspects turn out
.
yes.  So, I remember saying something like this to our
Assistant Manager Junhyeok when we first started studying this strategy
.  Uh, even when the price of Bitcoin is
fluctuating like this, Strategy will continue to
accumulate coins through paid-in capital increases. If it
trends upward again, the
valuation of the coins held within the company, accumulated at the low point, will
increase significantly.
So, later during a coin price surge,
since the value of what is already held will
rise along with the increase in the coin price, the stock price
could experience leverage.  I remember mentioning that, but
if the structure is such that cash keeps leaking out like this, we need to
recalculate it.  That’s what I’m
thinking.
you're right.  So, the reason
Bitcoin suddenly plummeted after successfully breaking through $70,000 this time was actually right
after Strategy sold 32 Bitcoins.  Regarding Strategy, Michael
Saylor
used the expression "innercule."  I got vaccinated in advance
.  So, he made a statement that was almost like a joke, saying that he had tested the market to show that our company
could sell Bitcoin,
demonstrating that flexibility
.  And uh, I
told individuals not to sell Bitcoin, but I
mentioned to institutions that we can sell it flexibly.
So, regarding the fact that Strategy and
Michael Saylor are aware of this part,
I also
got a bit of a feeling about it to some extent.  So, structurally, our cash flow is really
different from BitMY.  In Litma,
there is an Ethereum cash flow generated when you invest or stake Ethereum.  So, that is why the
story is a bit different, but yes.  In the case of that strategy,
since there is no cash flow even in the existing business unit, it
seems that structurally, they will have no choice but to sell Bitcoin.  And in
terms of taxes, while it certainly locks in losses, it
seems highly likely that this company will sell Bitcoin and use it somewhat as a financial tool.  So, it demonstrated that such actions are
possible during this downturn,
and I believe that when the next downturn comes
or as the structure continues to build, it will likely
show such a trend from time to time, perhaps even displaying signs of selling
.   yes
.  Lazy people like me might think about
investing in coins, but then wonder how to do it. I heard there is something called
electronic field sensing or something, but eventually, we might just end up completely clueless and decide to just buy a
strategy book.   It would be
very helpful if you could take better care of them in the future, especially for the sake of such people
.   yes
.  Some parts of today were quite
long.  I'm sorry.  I will see you shortly.
Since you have an external lecture today, I know you might be a little
disappointed, but I will host Part 2 as well
.  I would like to
thank the members of Chae Bum-turn who joined us.  I will
see you briefly at the upper level.  thank you
[Music]
Hello, Choi Milton.  We will now begin Part 2 of the
Chesley Morning Brief on the 18th, bringing you happy investment plans
.   As I
mentioned at the end, Jeom is
currently giving a lecture outside.   Since I am giving a
lecture right where you are all, I think there might be some of you, Choi Mi-ton, who are
there
.  If anyone happens to be there, it would be
fun to leave a [laughter] in the comments.
Some of you briefly mentioned how things went in the U.S. market yesterday and the
content of the speech, but I would like to
hear more details from the Vice President.
yes.  I came here this morning and
watched the FMC statement and the press conference.  Overall, I
sensed an atmosphere where some major changes could occur at the Fed.
First of all, if you look at the statement,
this is the full text.  hmm.
Previously, when I was doing the Power Jang, a whole page was completely
full,
yes.
Hey, the statement has become quite short this time
.  It has become very simplified.   hmm.
Some people say that this has become a bit
unfriendly, but
I actually
liked the feeling that it was concise and focused only on the essentials.
First of all, interest rates were frozen.
Since Mr. Chemino has been saying that prices could fall through the increase in production lines, I
thought that perhaps those aspects might be reflected in the FMC statement or press conference this time, but the
conclusion regarding that was rather lenient.
And rather, taking a somewhat neutral stance on
how changes to the Fed will occur, and
also regarding the abolition of some aspects such as Ford guidance.  And
he gave a message to not just look to the Fed, but to focus more on the data provided by the market instead.  First off,
regarding the details of the interest rate freeze, if you
look at the statement and just focus on the highlighted sections,
there is a part about productivity. It
stated that productivity growth and capital investment are strong, and regarding inflation, it said that the goal of reaching the
2% target remains
unchanged, while
emphasizing that the economy is currently evolving to a higher level than that
.   You
stated that the reason for the high is the rise in prices in specific sectors, including energy,
and the committee will achieve price stability
.  So, it was explained that
the will for price stability has been secured
.  And the SAP
Summary of Economic Projections
has been released. If you
look at the chart below,
GDP has
dropped from 2.4% to 2.2% compared to last March.
And as for the test rate, it
was 4.4% last March, but it dropped a bit to 4.3% this time
.
As for inflation, compared to last March, the
headline PC
rose by 0.9% to 9% points, from 2.7% to 3.6%.  And in the
case of core PC inflation, it
also increased from 2.7 to 3.3
.   With
inflation forecasted to be high, there was an
expectation last March that the federal funds rate might be cut to around 3.4% by the end of this year.
However, this time, the signal here appears to indicate a shift toward a
rate hike, perhaps exceeding expectations of a cut and suggesting a move toward 3.8% to 8%. If you
look closely at the dots next to it, there are
nine points indicating a rate hike within the year
.  And there are about eight stamps on the freezing side and
one stamp on the reduction side
.  So
generally, half are frozen or lowered, and the other half are frozen
or lowered.  The increase
was halved like this, and
Chairman Kivinusi just said that he did not vote for Jeomdeokpyo
.
Uh, the main point of the press conference was that they
abolished Ford guidance, stating that they would
move toward a more austere or more relaxed approach going forward
.  It was
giving a certain kind of signal, but they said they would not give such a signal anymore
.  And the
reason is that the Fed
abolished accord guidance with the intention of encouraging the market to focus more on current data, as the market works best when reacting to current data and providing guidance would actually cause confusion.
And they announced that they would launch five task forces in various fields,
explaining that they would develop and implement a framework by the end of the year. They stated that they plan to
launch five tasks in the form of communication, response table, data productivity, employment, and inflation frameworks, and
made remarks with the intent of recruiting new and innovative talents to conduct studies.   If
you look at the Q&A, since it was the first one today, it felt a bit unfamiliar and
strange. However, compared to before,
rather than providing detailed explanations, you can view it as an
explanation of the direction in which the Fed will change going forward
.  Uh, first of all, I was asked about
the background of the interest rate freeze and the assessment of the current economic situation.
[Clears throat] The economy is expanding steadily despite the uncertainty in the Middle East.
While the housing market is constrained,
considering the current interest rate situation, if we look at the
rise in stock prices, the
financial conditions do
not seem that restrictive.  So, I
mentioned that when considering the housing market and the financial market, the two sides seem somewhat unbalanced.
And the Balance Sheet Task Force stated that they
plan to review the policy transmission channels
.  I asked
about the implementation schedule for the five sectors of the Tescobus announced today, and they stated that
operations will begin within a few weeks, an
interim framework will be established in the fall, and a
final conclusion will be reached by the end of this year
.  When
asked if there was a possibility of revising the 2% inflation target, they stated that there are
no plans for revision
.  I asked why they are taking a wait-and-see approach without taking active measures, considering that the return to the inflation target is set for
2028, which is eight years away. If you
look back at the previous post, the target
date for achieving the inflation figure itself is set for 2028, so I
asked with the intent that something should be done now. They replied that while their
commitment to price stability is firm, they will not provide
specific policy measures until the next meeting
.   I
was asked what the background was for reducing the length of the statement and completely abolishing forward guidance. We have
secured the commitment to price stability, but we will not provide
specific details until the next meeting. Ah, I apologize.   He
said that the purpose is to eliminate the practice of the market looking only to the Fed, and that efficient markets will be made to respond directly to real economy data rather than the Fed.
When asked at the meeting whether there were any internal disagreements regarding the year-end interest rate outlook, it was true that the group was divided in half between those who wanted to raise rates and those who wanted to maintain the status quo, but this was
merely a difference in future outlook, and they said that they unanimously agreed on today's
decision to freeze rates and the price stability target
.
[Snicker] When asked about his views on the long-term path of inflation and
structural pressures, he
repeated that certain sectors, such as oil prices, are rising due to supply shocks, and that price stability will be achieved
.  I asked about the background behind the establishment of the Data Task Force and the
direction for securing data. They
stated that outdated survey statistics do not reflect the real-time economy, and that they would introduce real-time coincidence data analysis techniques into policy to reduce errors, similar to those used by private sector CEOs. I also asked whether the
idea that productivity improvement serves as a basis for interest rate hikes is valid. They
responded that while
AI is a major innovation and the U.S. will be a beneficiary, the
specific policy timing, scale, and
employment impact need to be closely examined through the newly established Productivity and Employment Task
Force
.  Uh, I was asked how to assess the
current employment market when synthesizing recent employment indicators, and I
said that a stable and strong, productivity-driven employment market—ah, employment growth—is not something to fear, but a factor to welcome.  So
there were a few questions regarding productivity, and in
response, they were somewhat reserved, saying that the grounds for the interest rate cut needed to be
examined further
.
Basically, the
press conference focused mainly on Bakkt, and you can
view it as a presentation of a blueprint for the Fed's future direction.  hmm.
After this press conference,
investors who were expecting at least a slightly more dovish stance seemed to be
dumping their shares, thinking, "There's nothing special about this
."  hmm.  The semiconductor sector also
showed signs of a slowdown in the rate of increase.
So, I’ve been thinking about the implications. If we
assume that an accommodative stance had been announced today, I think there would have been
some spread across stocks and sectors. However, it
seems the market reacted to the Fed’s hawkish sense in the short term.  If the stance had been accommodative,
sector expansion would have been possible. Depending on oil price
stability, interest rates
will likely stabilize, but it seems the situation will involve a somewhat hawkish stance
.  So, it seems the market will have to adapt to high interest rate levels for the time being
.  Ah, in that situation, it
seems the sector concentration will continue. If we
think about which direction the sectors are skewed—which is the
point the CEO chuckled about earlier—it
appears that the differentiation between sectors with strong growth momentum due to these high interest rate levels and those without will continue.  Therefore, I believe that the momentum will continue to be valid in the
AI ​​infrastructure sector, where the strongest momentum is currently sustained
.  That's all.
[Laughs]
Yes.
yes.  yes.
Uh, before I ask about the details, let me
give you the division first.
Yes.
Uh, regarding the second-to-last line, there will
be some differentiation between the side with strong profit momentum for high-interest rate level loans and the side without.
yes.  Yuri, since I am going to reach this conclusion,
some people
told me in advance to match the tone as well.   I used to be a
merchant, though.  [Laughs]
You did a good job.
yes.   yes
.  I think you're right.  Uh,
first off, [snorting] it is always like this
whenever the FOMC Chair gives a speech or holds a Q&A; today, it is the same in the comment section.
Uh, there is always so much back-and-forth about whether to listen to what you said
or to
believe there is some hidden message behind it, so
I’m conflicted too. To use an analogy, imagine playing Scissors with
our Vice President. You might think, "I’m just going to throw a rock
no matter what," but then the
Vice President might think, "
Oh,
what if I throw a shovel?"  hmm.
Then I have to play scissors.   hmm.
Uh, what if I throw that punch?  Then I have to pay the
bill.  If we keep going like this, there is
no end to it.  yes.   uh
.  Usually, our original text and um.  Since you are
hearing it live, are
we correct in interpreting the meaning between the lines?
Or is it
correct to simply understand what is being said as correct?
I think it's correct to understand it exactly as it is.  In this person's
case,
I didn't really sense any particular underlying meaning in their speech.   hmm.
So, first of all, it
seems there is a strong determination to fix the current state of the Fed in some way.  I think we should
view this as a situation where we are building up the momentum based on that determination, and the
vibe is kind of like, "I'm going to
fix it like this, so don't demand an answer right now
."  Oh, just
watch.  Also, I am
not in a position to say anything here, and since data is the
market, and the market will
react to immediate data, I do
n't think I need to go out of my way to mention it
. I think that was roughly the nuance
.  So, even
before the FMC, they said they
would reduce the Fed's role rather than having too much of it.  Ah, there have been a lot of talks like that, so
wouldn't their stance actually be somewhat like that?  hmm.
And wouldn't it be necessary to create five TESPS and go through a
process of redefining the direction the Fed should take going forward?  Ah,
in that process, since they asked for something when it hadn't been made yet, I
think there were some instances where the question and the answer were a bit off-topic.  yes.   yes
.  That was the feeling.   As
I was on my way to work this morning listening to the news, I heard you read an article comparing the
current situation with the last FMC meeting. You mentioned that
last time, no lawmaker said an interest rate hike was necessary in September, but
this time, almost everyone said so
. As a result, the market is concerned that an interest rate cut in September should be accepted as a foregone conclusion.
Was that inference too derived from watching the meeting and the Q&A?
I think so.  yes.  So, well, right
now, we have to consider it practically the
end of the war, don't we?
virtually.  And
there was news today about an agreement on M. From my perspective, although things are as they are
now, once
Hormuz's economy opens up and oil price trends
stabilize,
prices that rose due to oil prices will naturally come down a bit. So, would
n't the stance change slightly in about six weeks?   I have
no choice but to come to this conclusion.  Would
n't it turn out like this?  But I do
n't know what will happen in the future.  I have to look at the data again
.  Don't ask what will happen in the future.   I
think it might turn out like this.   yes
.
Well, we'll have to wait and see whether interest rates will continue to be raised or lowered in the future,
but it
seems the tone regarding the need to make more conservative decisions due to inflation will ease somewhat.  It is the Word.  yes.  yes.
That is correct.  Judging by the current situation, it seems like that might be the case
.  Ah, I think that given the
circumstances of the past
, the choice had no choice but to turn out this way
.  Because,
even at the time of that meeting,
the agreement between Iran and the U.S. was likely not completely finalized, so I
think those aspects might not have been reflected as much.  So, in my
opinion, the prices of PCs and coffee beans were likely recorded as
slightly higher than they actually were, or perhaps estimated to be higher
.  I think
this
issue might be alleviated a little more if we try it now or in a few days
.  [Clears throat] Yes.
All right.  This is the last question.  Um, to get back to the point, this is
part of the Global Insight materials that our interns saw last Sunday. I
assume the Vice President probably missed it because he is currently on a business trip.
yes.  As for what was protected, ah, it
was the Golden Marsdax punt data,
was it from 1952?  After that, if we plot the
level of the U.S. 10-year Treasury yield on the x-axis and the rise or fall of
SMP 500 stocks over the next six months
on the Y-axis, we
see that when the 10-year Treasury yield
is in the range of 4 to 4.5% or higher than 5%, the
SMP 500 stocks over the next six months
start to fall more often than rise; and when it goes above
5%, the
chances of it falling are much higher. So,
looking at the 10-year Treasury yield and thinking, "Oh, it's gone
over 4.5%..."  Well, if
we consider this to be a somewhat sensitive point, that was the
gist of it. To
paraphrase this slightly: the
higher the interest rate, the lower the
expectation for the index itself to rise, and thus,
investment based on more thorough analysis of individual stocks or sectors
becomes more important.  I guess it's okay to just paraphrase it like this
.
Oh, that's obvious.  Because, well, interest
rates aren't trending at 5%,
6%, or 7% here, are they?
And even so, there
is no way it will go down from the 4.5% level to 3.5%.
So, I think it will move at the 4 to 4.5% level
.  I also
think it will be difficult to break through 4% and go down,
so from the stock market's perspective,
how would they view the 4 to 4.5% range?  If you
think about it,
when comparing bonds with the stock market as a whole,
those who invest in the stock market or market indices themselves might have some concerns
.  Uh, however,
since earnings momentum varies by stock within that market index, as
I mentioned earlier, there will be differentiation between stocks with
strong earnings momentum capable of overcoming high interest rates
and those that do not. So
, if we look at the market capitalization alone, while it has
risen by almost 90% to 100% this year
, the S&P 500 hasn't even risen by 10%
.  In that sense, it
seems that portfolio management capabilities in this high-interest rate environment will effectively determine future performance.   yes
.  In this process, stocks and sectors related
to AI—including those in the old and new economies—
are currently leading the market, but if
valuations become excessively high
or if
there is a point where momentum peaks out, we will do our best to pinpoint it for you
.   In
the US [snorting] market, FOMC
Chairman Kevin Orsey delivered his first speech
.  We looked into this with our CEO, Mr. Choi
.  That’s all for the
US market for today; let’s
move on to the Korean market.   I ask
our village head for a favor.   yes
.  I will now report on yesterday's market.   The
KOSPI index closed up 1.6%, and the
KOSDAQ closed up about 1.3%
.  In terms of supply and demand,
individual investors saw an inflow of buying in the range of 500 billion won
.  Foreign investors had been net buying for three
consecutive days but sold about 1 trillion won on the previous trading day, while
institutions have been net buying for four consecutive days
.  There
was an inflow of buying pressure of about 600 million won.
In foreign futures, there was approximately 780 billion won in futures
purchases.
Looking at the trends by investor type, foreign investors
bought SK Nix, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Hyundai Motor, Kia, Hyundai Rotem, LIG, DNA, and others.  For selling, SK
Square, HPSP, LG
Innotek, Seojin Systems, Kiwoom Securities,
Hanmi Semiconductor, etc. were sold.
During the period, I bought SK Inix, Samsung Electronics, SK
Square, Korea Shipbuilding & Marine Engineering, Kiwoom Securities,
etc.   For
the sell orders, I sold Hyundai Motor, Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
Samsung SDI, HPSP, Chusung
Engineering, and others.  A
total of 17 stocks hit 52-week highs.
Kospis, SK Inix, SK
Square, SK Holdings, Lotte Shopping,
Hyundai Department Store, and Korea Circuit were at new
highs.  KOSDAQ consists of small
stocks.  YG1, Yeti,
Hwashin, and others hit new highs. Hmm,
is there a reason why our Ogajang seems a bit lacking in energy today?
Ah, I've had a bit of a cold lately, so
yes.  Uh, I'm young, but I wear long sleeves.
All right.  [Laughs]
Yes.  You need to protect your mental health from the air conditioner
.  yes.  [Laughs]
Uh.  [Snoring] Uh, recently I've been
looking at the investor trading trends that Manager Oh summarizes. If
you look here, ETFs stand out quite a bit among the top stocks bought by institutions. I often wonder if they are buying and selling
individual
stocks solely because of ETFs, but do you
see any stocks that don't seem to be the case?  So, are there any stocks where you get the feeling that
individual stock trading didn't happen because of ETF trading?
It seems like shipbuilding stocks are a bit like that.  There were some cases where foreigners lived in the house as well, and well, I don't
think there is anything particularly different.  Well, regarding
things like automobiles, there are
certainly investments utilizing automotive ETFs.
So, just as you mentioned, CEO, it feels like
ETFs are dominating the market these days
. It seems like the semiconductor materials, parts, and equipment sector is entering the market in a similar way.   The
supply and demand...
um,
I understand.  I’ll
ask our Deputy Seon-gu just one thing about the stocks that went up below before
moving on.  Uh, well,
because of Hynix S, Square is good, SK is
good, and everything seems to be like that.  Those
aspects are immediately and intuitively
understandable. Last week, we discussed the timeline for
our retail companies amidst the earthquake.
[Clears throat] Uh, regarding
Lotte Shopping, Hyundai Department Store, and
Shinsegae (though not here), uh [
snorted] a significant portion of the reason their stock prices are performing well is
likely due to the
spending by foreigners visiting Korea and generating department store
sales.
Looking at the valuations, should we consider that these factors to
be reflected to some extent
?  Or
should we consider that there is still a significant amount of expectation remaining?
Uh, regarding what I mentioned at the time,
actually, the effect on
domestic residents is much,
uh, much more than the effect on foreigners
. I am sorry.   I
mentioned this before, but
uh, in addition to that, since the
ceiling for foreigners has risen a bit, I
understand that all three companies proceeded with the bean program last week.  It appears that the
stock
price gained further momentum and rose immediately after the concrete was executed, which indicated that foreign investors had already increased their weight to high single digits when the process was underway
.   yes
.
Now, I have a vivid memory of a chart from when we were doing Boxree where the proportion of sales to foreigners was around 14% or something. It’s
stuck in my head
, so I guess I briefly misunderstood the contents of our Box
.  I
understand that it is around 7% in Korea, but the content was that it went up
to about 13% in the case of Japan.
However, what was different from Japan was that
the proportion of luxury goods sold in department stores is much higher in Korea than in street shops, so they
said that is a unique characteristic of Korea.   I
conveyed the opinion that there is a high possibility that Korea's share will increase beyond 13%.  If you go to places like Japan, you can see
luxury brand shops right on the streets in the city
center, but in Korea, I don't think I've
seen them much—except maybe in specific spots like Cheongdam-dong.
you're right.
So, when tourists come, they
often go to Myeongdong.  There are
no such road shops in Myeongdong.   hmm.
There isn't.   yes
.  no.  Since they are all department stores, we can assume that perhaps
all such purchasing demand is taking place at department stores
.
The proportion of foreigners
was about 4% as of the first quarter.  [Clears throat]
And 100% points, yes.  It was roughly
similar, and
recently, the rate of increase has
risen to about 7% as of May.   yes
.  It has risen to 7%, and
judging by the current pace, we are currently predicting that it will
not be able to reach double digits by the end of this year
.   yes
.  Uh, have you ever seen things like
15x or 20x based on department store PR standards
?  It happened about 20 years
ago.   I
think I saw it wrong.  yes.  [Laughs]
So, it’s unfamiliar, but I think I need
to carefully check the performance here so that I can confidently make a move and hold onto it even at this kind of
valuation
.  It is true that we are most interested
in semiconductors and their related value chains,
but when looking at other institutions and individuals, they are
recording quite good performance in portfolios outside of that. I asked because I thought that back pain could
also be one of those sectors
.   Let's
move on.  Please proceed to the next step
.  Manager.   hmm.
Regarding the semiconductor materials, parts, and equipment sector,
Samsung Electronics
rose by over 1% yesterday in the large semiconductor sector.  SK Hynix
showed a strong upward trend of 5.8%.  Recently,
Hynix's stock price seems to be performing relatively better than Samsung Electronics. This could be attributed to the
imminent ADR listing.
Also, I heard that
the pricing for HBM is expected to be determined around July or August of next year. Given this,
isn't the buying pressure shifting more strongly toward Hynix, which has greater exposure to HBM?  yes.
I have that thought.  But then I saw that
Hynix had surpassed Electronics' P-number again
.  yes.   If I
mention this in the morning, there is a tendency for
the former to catch up or something like that after a few weeks, so it
seems we will have to wait and see how things turn out.   yes
.  It seems the materials, parts, and equipment sector is a bit
mixed these days.  There is a trend where if one place
rises significantly, another falls a bit,
and then moves in the opposite direction the next day;
HPSP has dropped by about 5%.   It did hit the
upper limit recently, and
I asked the researchers about it. As far as
I know, the only reason is the Terra issue, so I
asked if there were any other reasons for it to go up, but they said there were
n't.  hmm.
So, just like how LG-
related stocks rose after Jensen, I think the market
reacted sensitively to even small positive news because it is such a volatile environment
.  And regarding the equipment stocks below,
stocks like EOTech, Park Systems, and Wonik IPS
seemed to have generally performed well.  In the circuit board sector,
Simtek rose 2.6% and Daeduck Electronics 2.5%, so the
circuit board industry was
not bad either.  In the IT sector, the electric vehicle sector appeared somewhat
weak, but LG Electronics and LG
Innotek showed an upward trend.  In the platform
sector, Naver
showed an upward trend of about 0.6%.  And the Nikkei
index showed an upward trend of about 0.7% to 7% yesterday, and
semiconductors are doing
very well here as well.  Tokyo Electron
rose 2.5%.  Uh, Murata was 3%,
and Hoya and Disco 2-Biden were generally all showing
strong trends.  So, Ibiden's
forward value has risen to 90 times
.  It seems that most equipment stocks are
trading at more than 40 times their value
.  Based on those criteria, are
n't there still some domestic materials, parts, and equipment stocks that offer some merit?  I also have that thought.
In the battery chain, LG Ener Solution
closed 1.3% higher.  There was
no significant movement in the remaining items.  Well, the automotive
sector took a breather yesterday.
Hyundai Motor, Kia, and the rest of the stocks also
generally showed a sluggish trend.  The consumer goods
sector was mixed.  There
were some stocks that rose, with Classys surging 3.7%,
Pharma 2.3%, and Hujeri about 7%
.  The APR was also
good.  It seems like the skin care and beauty device
sectors were doing pretty well yesterday, but as for the
food and beverage sector, it
looks like there is still no buying momentum.
Nongshim's pharmaceutical products only
saw a growth rate of about 3 people.
Shipbuilding stocks performed very well in the shipbuilding sector, including steel, sweeteners, and other sectors
.  There weren't any special issues yesterday
.  Hyundai Heavy Industries, Hana Ocean, and Hana
Engine all rose, but Hana Engine's
upward trend was steep.   It was the one that
dropped the most.
Looking at the chart within the shipbuilding sector, the stock price had pulled back all the gains driven by engine momentum,
causing the
valuation to drop below 20 times. As a result, it
seems that bargain buying flowed in.  The steel and chemical sector below was a bit
sluggish.  In the stock market, Hana and Yeoro
rose 3.5%, while Nex, Hyundai, and Rotem
were weak.
Uh, yesterday
when we were discussing the defense industry, I mentioned that X1 and
Rheinmetall are collaborating
.  However, up until Cheonggung 2,
L-Nex 1 has a significant influence, but when
moving to LSAM, the influence of Hanaro and the other systems
increases.  Now, the Li
X1 plays the role of overseeing the missile system,
and [snorting]
Aerospace mainly
handles the launch vehicle and ammunition side, but when we
move on to the LSM, it's about altitude, isn't it?   The
role of the projectile becomes significantly important.
Accordingly, I believe there are
aspects to look forward to regarding Hanaro or the Hanaro System in the future.
If Nex
rises with such Heaven momentum or LSM momentum, then eventually, a
trend in which Hanaro follows suit may emerge, so please keep that in mind when
watching
.  In the bio sector, Samsung
Biologics rose 2.8%, while
Episis was at a weak level.  It seems like
biotech stocks on the KOSDAQ performed quite well yesterday
.  Also, there has been a lot of talk about government policies to
revitalize the KOSDAQ
.  Perhaps due to some influence, companies such as
Alteogen, ABL
Biotron, and DND showed an upward trend
.
Oh, and regarding bank stocks, KB Financial
was a bit weak yesterday.  Stock prices were also
quite weak.  It closed with a decline of about 5.4%, and in the
entertainment sector,
HYIVE fell by 5.6%,
while JP and YG showed an upward trend, and the
mentor sector has also recently
shown a slight turnaround.  So,
the changes below weren't bad either, but the
Hyundai Diary remained flat, while the rest generally
showed a weak trend.  So, the entertainment sector
currently has a lower value than department stores or duty-free chains
.  Excluding HYBE, YG,
SMGP, and
Shinsegae are currently trading at 17 to 18 times their value
.  So,
even compared to distributors, [sneers] its current value is low, and if you look further up,
Samyang Foods also has a
better current value than distribution chains.
Because it is increasing by 14 times, it
feels like department stores are currently somewhat linked to semiconductor-related stocks. If
semiconductor stock prices go up, the market will be good, so
investors will make a lot of money and
then go to department stores to spend it.  Ah, the
income effect.  yes.  I
believe that kind of content was probably covered in the box, but
uh, there is some differentiation in that aspect.
So, actually, if you look only at the actual situation and
stability, something like a commercial
product is a better choice, but it seems
the market thinks there are more momentum
players
.  Such thoughts.   I heard that people are
putting everything into semiconductor stocks instead of spending money because you can make a quick profit from them.
[Laughs] Some even
say you should sell your underwear to buy semiconductors.
Then isn't that negative income?  [Laughs] It
probably varies from person to person.  It
probably varies from person to person.  yes.  Since everyone has different opinions—some are
scared because semiconductor prices have risen too much, while others believe this is just the
beginning—I
think everyone's situation and judgment will differ.
When you talk about stock price trends most recently, I noticed that the market has
n't really been discussing this lately, and that was with companies
like Samsung Electro-Mechanics
.  If you look at the earnings of companies like Samsung Electro-Mechanics in
a bit more detail,
the valuation might differ slightly from what is shown in this table, but well, it's
eight times. However,
Murata is 50 times. Excluding stocks where the PR appears high because the
earnings are so poor compared to any other stock in the world,
among stocks where the multiple has increased alongside earnings, it seems like it might be number one on Earth, or maybe
not.
But usually, when the market is like this, it feels
burdensome.   You're
commenting on this again, but it
seems like people are saying that a little less these days.   I
think it's also because I prefer it.
Oh, really?  The exact same as SDI?   I
don't prefer SDI, and I'm
trying hard to take a cut from below it, but it's
not going very well.   As for
electricity, I did mention
a bit about it when I went out to Hankyung yesterday,
yes.  [Snoring] Based on
my personal estimation of MLCCs, the
step price of MLCCs at Samsung Electro-Mechanics was about 5 won based on their confirmed earnings for the first quarter.
But the thing is, the price increase hasn't appeared yet
.  So,
looking at it quarterly since 2023, there have been almost no price increases
.  However, now that a shortage has
started and price increases are occurring,
looking at past cases—
I went all the way back up to COVID-19—it was
only IT demand that experienced a shortage in MCC demand
.
The price went up by about 30% back then, too
.  Prices have been steadily rising for about a year and a half to two years, but it means my
price life has
n't even started yet.  However,
performance is currently strong,
so if we assume that it rises to
around 6.7 or 7 won next year, the
estimated operating profit for the MLCC business unit
comes out to about 2 trillion won.  If you
apply Murata's valuation of 55 times to 2 trillion,
the value of MLCCs comes out to 110 trillion just from that.  But well, looking at the
Flash BJ and camera modules, based on my
SOTP analysis, the
market capitalization could potentially
reach around 180 trillion won. However, [snorting] there is
one risk regarding the valuation. We calculated this by applying
55x leverage for Murata and
90x leverage for Ebidan. If the industry trend
reverses, or if the pace of unit price increases is slower than we expect, we are essentially
receiving 90x or 55x leverage based on expectations
.  It can suddenly take a sharp turn
.   hmm.
That aspect is a bit risky, but I
think it is a shame to worry about it when price hikes haven't even started yet. So, regarding Samsung Electronics,
if you like semiconductors, you definitely need to keep an eye on these three: Samsung, SK Hynix, and Samsung Electric
.
That
was a prepared answer.  hmm.  Could you give us
some evaluation, Mr. Director? Well,
since I've been exclusively handling the US since then, I have
n't really looked at your attitude, but I do have some
old memories.  So, back when
Samsung Electro-Mechanics was doing much better,
there was a period when they were performing exceptionally well, and I heard them talking about that during their
IR presentations
.  It is not a problem with Samsung Electro-Mechanics, but rather that
a rise is occurring because the industry conditions are so good.   hmm.
yes.  So, when I look at it, I
consider two things: the growth potential of the market and the
industry the company belongs to, and the
company's competitiveness.
Hmm, taking
those factors into account, is this 88x multiple
reasonable?  hmm.
Uh, these parts are good, but
ah, aren't they a bit over the top?   hmm.   I do
n't really understand this kind of worry.  It worked out even from the perspective of someone who didn't know
.  yes.  So,
considering the future profit momentum of the semiconductor sector,
Samsung Electronics, SK Harrix, and
Micron are trading at around 6x, 7x,
or 10x, while SanDisk is
trading around 10x.
When comparing Samsung Electro-Mechanics, which is trading at 88x, with the memory sector, if I were to consider which side
has more investment appeal—and
this isn't a matter of absolutes, but just a rough estimate—well, although there
is still debate about whether or not it has a cyclical nature, I
think I would still prefer the memory sector a little more
.  yes.  When our leader, Mr. Oh, logically explained why he
views Samsung Electro-Mechanics favorably, he
also mentioned the parts of that logic that can be understood
.  Looking at it, since it rose by
cyclically referencing Japan's top-tier stocks, when
they come down, they similarly come
down by cyclically referencing them.  yes.  So, I
think we need to carefully consider those aspects before investing.
All right.  Now, shall we
move on to the report you prepared?  I brought up the distribution side, and
oh, there happened to be distribution available.  yes.  It seems they expect
some effect from the structural improvement of the three department store businesses
.  This was
material from Researcher Park Jong-dae.  We anticipate that
the improvement of Baekgeon 34's business structure will
result in a 10% increase in operating profit
.  It is a situation where we can expect both profit
improvement and stock price momentum driven by rising valuations
. Within this, the profit trend can be divided into the
divergence effect caused by rising stocks, real estate, and wages, and the
impact of new demand from foreign inbound tourism
.  Additionally,
the effect of improving the business structure of individual companies is also
significant.  The
projected growth rate of the consolidated operating profit of the three department store companies in 2026 is
forecast to be 39% based on consensus, and it is analyzed that about
10 percentage points of this is due to business restructuring
.
You mentioned Lotte Shopping first, and
the forecast is that operating profit might increase by 5% due to the scrapping of low-efficiency stores. It is said that Lotte Shopping is scrapping
low-efficiency stores annually in its current department store business, such as the Masan and Bundang branches
.  This year as well, we can expect an annual profit improvement of 5 billion won
in this area
.  It was also stated that the e-commerce business is
thoroughly shifting toward profitability, and
through the reduction of fixed costs, improvement of category mix, and enhancement of advertising revenue, the operating deficit is
projected to be reduced from 2529 billion won to approximately 15 billion won this year.
In addition, it is said that there are business sectors where operating leverage effects can be expected due to fixed cost reductions, and that
hypermarkets are
continuing to improve their gross profit margins through integrated sourcing with department stores and supermarkets
.  Home shopping is seeing an increase in revenue as annual
broadcasting fees amounting to approximately 360 billion won have
stagnated since 2025
.  Cultureworks says that the
burden of labor costs has significantly decreased since COVID-19
.  The film market is
showing a steep improvement trend, influenced by recovery.
However, it is said that
operating losses are expected to widen in the second half of the year due to the launch of the online food business, Zeta
.  It is
acting as a factor of uncertainty. I discussed this part
.  I
spoke with Shinsegae as well, and they said that they expect a
6% increase in operating profit, reaching 10.6%, due to the effects of the original renewal
.
Uh, first of all, I believe the effect of the main branch's renovation is
quite significant. It is said that operations were suspended for
70% of the main building's space from April to November of the previous year
.  Uh, it appears that sales growth of around 60% year-on-year has been recorded from the reopening in November of last year through
June of this year
.  In addition, it is said that
uncertainty regarding duty-free sales is also being significantly alleviated, and that the
Incheon Airport DF2 business, which had been recording annual operating losses of over 50 billion won, was
suspended last April
.   hmm.
Department store chain stocks have been performing very
well recently, and their valuations have
risen significantly as well.
When I previously discussed department store retail chains, I
showed you the valuation tables for the Kinshi group’s Shinsegae and Hyundai Department Stores using Bloomberg data;
in the past, the upper end of our department store's valuation was
16 to 17 times.   The
period spans about
20 years,
from 2010 to about 14 years, and the
last 10 years or so. However, the
highest point during that period was when the number of
Chinese tourists was very high;
at that time, it was about 17 times higher, and currently, based on
Shinsegae standards, the
PR has increased by about 17 times.
Uh, I
think it was about 13 times when I mentioned it last time.
So back then, I said there seemed to be about 30 to
40 percent upside remaining, but
now, looking only at past examples, I
think it is right at the top of the valuation.  However, if we
look at what needs to be done to raise the stock price further, the estimates need to
come out well. Only then will the consensus be
adjusted, causing the valuation to
fall. In fact, regarding that,
Shinsegae releases earnings reports every month, and
looking at them, the May results were
very good.  So, those
estimates are being reflected now, and
personally, I find it difficult for the valuation to go over 20 times from here. I wonder if
the market might move just about as much as the consensus is adjusted from around this valuation level?
Also, since there are
many cases where valuations are ignored when momentum comes in these days, it
might be apologized for now.
Well, it might be possible to break through beyond that, but
anyway, it is in the distribution sector. As
I mentioned in the Japanese case study last time, even Japanese
companies peaked at exactly 19 to 20 times.
So, looking at it that way, even
though Japan is one of the countries with a much more robust domestic market than ours, the fact that its valuation has
n't expanded beyond that suggests that there might
not be many opportunities here to make a big profit based on valuation.
Personally, I do have that thought a bit
.  Looking at the table below, you can see the Shinsegae
stock price and EPS trends.  The
one on the right is definitely different from Hyundai Department Store.
As shown in Hyundai Department Store's recent earnings, Jinus's deficit is quite large, so while the
department store side is not bad,
Jinus is eating up a lot of profits.   You
can know this.  The EPS
estimates were indeed adjusted very drastically
.  Based on Shinsegae standards.
So, since you can check every month whether it can continue to rise in a step-by-step manner, I
think you should take note of that aspect regarding Shinsegae.  And below are the
sales growth rate and
operating profit margin of Isetan Michikoshi;
I referenced Daishin Securities data for this.  It
is a Japanese company.  I was in a Japanese department store van, and
Chinese audience members came in in droves on the 22nd, 23rd, 24th, and
20th.  hmm.
Looking at the line trends, you
can see that things were very good. You can also see that
the stock price, valuation, and earnings all
rose together in line with the upward trend of the stock price of Michigoshi, which is similar on the right, and the number of foreign visitors to Japan
.  Recently, the number of Chinese tourists going to Japan has
dropped sharply, so that portion is
now flocking to Korea.
I think it would be fine if you looked at it that way.
thank you  It seems we are now passing the phase where the
stock price surged as earnings and multiples simultaneously improved. It looks like
our
leader is anticipating a phase where the stock rises steadily in accordance with earnings, much like how Samyang Foods steadily climbed based on its utility indicators. Yes, that is
correct.  Even though Type 3 Foods
had a quarterly surprise of 100%, its
valuation couldn't go above 20 times,
or it went up but then got pulled over
.  hmm.  So,
looking at that, wouldn't retail or duty-free department stores be
similar?
All right.  It has been quite a while since today, so regarding the
distribution, we also did our boxes last week, or
was it last week?
I did it last week.  Uh, we covered that last week, and since there is a brief
comment from our Deputy Director Seonbu today, we will stop
here and move on to looking at the
EXE materials from Committee Member Lee Eun-taek, who appears the most
.   yes
.  There was material from Researcher Entech.
History says that when there is a surge in leading stocks, it is a
good time. Actually, it has been a
very long time since Researcher Lee In-taek made this point, and
I have utilized this content quite a lot
.
However, since this is no different from the material I wrote previously, I will just
skip the details and get straight to the
point:
ultimately, regardless of
whether interest rates rise or
not, if rates go up, the
concentration of investment in leading stocks is bound to intensify
.  They say that was the case during the DaCombe era
.
As the Vice President
mentioned earlier, if interest rates rise, buying interest is bound to gravitate toward sectors with high earnings visibility
.   In the
domestic market, that
becomes an AI-related stock.  The researcher is saying that the market is bound to
shift toward sectors like semiconductors and transformers
.  Now, looking at the data below,
three sectors led the Da-Com bubble from 1995 to 1998:
biotech,
financial stocks, and IT. However, after interest rates were
raised, the SMP 500
weakened somewhat, while the Nasdaq
became very strong.  People wondered what else had
risen, and eventually, everything
gravitated solely toward AI semiconductors.
Ah, back then it was the internet side.   They mentioned that the market was
concentrated only on related stocks, and on
the right side, they said it includes the financial sector's 12-month forward rate, the
securities sector's rate, and the healthcare
sector,
but apparently, all of these parts were eventually
eliminated during the DaComber era.  They say that everyone
flocked only to the internet, and I
think that is the part I wanted to talk about.  Therefore, if
supply and demand spread to sectors other than AI and a collective rally occurs where everything rises together, there is
no possibility that this is the peak.
There are even stories like that.   hmm.
[Laughs]
Our Ojang was born in the 90s, so Modori
shouldn't use words like that.
Ah, the main gate has arrived.  [Laughs]
Thank you.  yes.
I don't think the content is much different from what you have repeated a few times recently.
So let's take a look. Lastly, here
[snorting], if you look at numbers 1, 2, and 3
written in large, bold letters, you can see that
current investors are showing the exact same investment patterns as investors 30 years ago.
Even without performance, if it's DaCom, it rises. Even now, even
without performance, if they say they are doing AI robots, it
skyrockets. That tone is like Oh Jang
[laughs]. That's exactly what I
learned. I'm
suspicious that Manager Oh uploaded the original text exactly as it is, but it is the original text. Ah,
that original report.
Ah, exactly as it is.
Uh, seriously, for some reason, the way you speak
sounds like Manager Oh’s voice has been patched in like this [laughs].
So, you know how LG CNS and
LG Electronics went up recently?   yes
.   When
I saw those stocks going up back then, I
thought, "Uh, the market is a bit scary."
Because it wasn't directly linked to earnings, and it's
not that
stocks like LG CNS or Samsung STS are bad companies,
yes.
Even though they were companies with not much merit, seeing them hit the upper limit made me
think, "Ah, the market is a bit unstable
."  So,
my friends invest a lot in stocks too, and they told me they
bought a lot of LG CNS because I was like, "Hey, isn't LG CNS good?"
I knew everyone was stuck with losses right now, so I strongly advised against
approaching such things lightly, but I noticed that a
lot of individual investors were actually going in that direction.
[Snicker] It's
really important to be selective with your investments, and
now I just need to watch Omega's... ah, I really need to go... but
what's the win rate like on Ogajang these days?   I
believe it is around 57
.   As far as
I remember, it always stuck at around 60% and then
dropped a little, but
now it is in positive territory.
So,
what happens today?   Ah, was it from that?
Uh, who did I do first?  Uh, from
America, from
America,
boss, is it lamb today?  Ah, today
is an up.  Because after the
FMC press conference ended, it seems like some
people who had
expectations bought some stocks
.  It's just Nephis,
yes.  I sold it thinking, "Uh, there's nothing special about it
."  But as
time went by, the speed of selling
called for selling upon selling, practically giving
back the entire upward trend, so,
uh, it seems like all 83s have done it
.
But after the market closed, uh, whatever M or whatever,
MU was also signed, and regarding Apple, we need to
raise prices because of memory specifications
.   hmm.
Since these factors are being reconfirmed and memory bottlenecks are being
identified, we
believe that a memory-centric rally could appear in the US market today.
Also, as Yuripro mentioned earlier, we
need to continue expanding the market map; therefore,
analyses are emerging that the semiconductor equipment cycle could be stronger and longer than before.   yes
.
So, uh, it’s not like it’s going to go up several times like memory, but
um, would
n’t it just follow a steady upward trend?  And now,
sectors like memory and equipment
occupy the top spots in the market capitalization of the index
.  So, for now, I think
those factors will likely drive the Philban index in the short term
.
All right.
Bang Seung, regarding our Yuri Pro, yes, I also see
both SP and Marsdaq
rising.  Regarding the MC, I
think we have somewhat digested the shock that has already occurred, and the 19th is another
recess.  The United States.   yes
.  What day is it?   It's called
Juntint Holiday, and they say it's
related to the emancipation of slaves.  So, since the market is closed,
trading volume might decrease a bit, but I still
expect a rebound.  All right.
The US is rising across the board.
yes.
We bought a few more minutes of time
.  Did you go grocery shopping?  Did it
stick to the top of the Bollinger Band again?
Ah, [laughs] I haven't looked at the chart.   yes
.
Since I came in with the answer already decided,
ah, yes.   There is a
high possibility of beekeeping.   hmm.
And looking at it yesterday, just
as Researcher Lee Eun-taek mentioned, since interest rates were
raised, everything else fell, and the market
went only toward semiconductor-related stocks in the U.S.  Seeing how only equipment stocks like Micron and
AMD are rising, and since the
index eventually rises when the semiconductor sector moves,
I think there is a high possibility of a bullish candle.  So, I will try wrapping it up again today
.  All right.
What is happening with KOSDAQ?   This
is Anbong.   huh
.   This
is Nunbong.
Eyeball  Uh,
the reason is
[laughs].
What is the reason?  You should
n't say things like that.  We are, uh, people who analyze and do things
.
Ah, yes.  What, what, what [laughs]
So, since the result is coming out, it's a bearish candle, yes.   I
have indicated it.  [Clears throat]
Uh,
according to my model, according to my system, it
is a bearish candle.  Let's put it this way.
What is the reason?  Then [laughs] it's
awkward, isn't it?
yes.
All right.  Then, is it
possible to predict tomorrow as well?  Or do I need to check the
market or something today
?   I need to go grocery shopping
today.
Hmm.  All right.  Today, I am a
beekeeper.  yes.   The
chicken in the course is a bearish candle.   yes
.  All right.  Today's Cheslick morning
briefing is a little past 9.  We will wrap up Part 10
here.
I hope you have a happy and enjoyable investment day today. It is
hot.  Please understand the health aspect, and if you
have any questions, please leave them. Since you also
check the Jeomlip, I think Washinbak will likely provide an answer
.  I would like to wrap up by thanking all of
you, Choi Mil-tan, for staying with us for such a long time through Part 2 today
.
thank you  thank you   ah